[Applause]
if
[Applause]
hey what's up gangsters gonna be here
this time skin
I hate carpool lanes and feel like
carpool lanes it's like society thing
hey you know how you're lonely yeah do
it for long be a loser watch people with
friends whizzing by you that's what's
out carpooling it's their [ __ ] I
think it's funny that Tanner is a white
person's name
thinner than one you know it should be
like hey this is my Mexican friend
tanner
that's my black friend tannest
something's jerking around telling
people an [ __ ] I was walking up an
escalator and this dude was on the left
hand side I think excuse me so we got
out of the way but then goes like dude
what if you walk up escalators that
doesn't make any sense because but then
I didn't hear how he ended that sentence
I was covering so much [ __ ] distance
[Music]
you don't have to make friends at you
fast enough a lot of people are like
yeah well it's your book smart but I
have street smart oh you're smart no way
that's not measured more comparable
I'm glad that my douchebag friends are
don't have any power or any
responsibilities
I think dudes are done I'm glad that
women give birth I feel like men gave
birth they do like bro
I'm eating so much protein and creatine
or my pregnancy this Baker they're 27
pounds really bro check in a six-pack in
the ultrasound the love of gain to the
first trimester not healthy bro brought
the baby I was talking to this girl she
was like did you know that my vagina is
a 3d printer makes a baby look like it's
a 3d printer I was like that's not even
accurate okay your womb is the 3d
printer your vagina is the tray
it's not even a very good 3d printed no
comforts one thing with lots of errors
it takes nine months to print and the
whole time is printing it's complainings
did not say they put your trades that
night some of my absolute in this mobile
phone a guy who is like dude we're so
lucky we're not gay can you imagine most
of the gender that you're attracted to
wasn't attracted to back that's what
it's like gay people write down some
ladies I love gay people I don't
understand homophobia some people will
say it's Adam and Eve I had a bit steep
which I don't think make any sense to
Adam and Eve were a terrible couple
okay first of all they disobeyed God and
they ate a fruit which is kind of gay
and then there's some Cain murdered that
other son Abel what we taking parenting
advice are people raised a murderer
there are only three other people on
earth this psychopathic I can't
one of these [ __ ] has to go just move
you got the whole learn you don't have
to kill the quarter of the world's
population you're starting to be [ __ ]
together
I love the new trends going on right now
the gender is tough I'm very gender
fluid myself I am biologically male but
my bullies identified me as a [ __ ] I
think people who are suicidal deserve
the same respect we get to transgender
people ok they're not suicidal they
identified the dead body so let them
transition into a course their program
is it I don't think that suicidal people
should use their bathroom so because
they make a mess I am Asian over the
phone this country of Chinese province
in china called south korea
I love being Asian because whenever
people are racist to me I'm like oh you
hate respectful people who keep to
themselves okay good luck finding an
affordable car
[Applause]